like you got a single best chart here
yes I'm not quitting but this is all
about quitting today's single best chart
comes from Deutsche Bank chief economist
chief internationally economist
Thorstein slack he's our guest host next
hour on surveillance the chart shows
look at this how people are voluntarily
quitting jobs and a pre crisis rate the
number of people who feel secure enough
to leave their jobs and look for another
one has risen dramatically over the last
few years and it's back to where we were
right when the financial crisis was
getting underway at the same time that
interest rates have remained pegged to
zero you notice how they had tracked the
quit rate reasonably well over the years
and now people are leaving their jobs
but the Fed hasn't moved more evidence
and Janet Yellen has mentioned this that
the Fed is starting to get to the point
where it might feel behind the curve and
I love charts like this the divergence
is so clear the tracking between the
federal funds target rate and the the
quit rate is so clear until we hit the
zero bound and then they completely
diverse and of course one of Janet
yellen's favorite indicators - isn't it
yeah it is she has mentioned this it's
something that she's watching she
brought it up yesterday in her press
conference and you know the title of
that chart we got to get out of this
place the old animal song yeah not just
about quitting but it may also refer to
the Fed at the zero bound exactly we
have luigi's and gals from the Chicago
Booth School with us that indicator tore
some slack from Deutsche Bank looks at
it looks the quit rate looks at rising
and sees inflation is that what you see
the first thing is we see a better labor
market which is that that's the most
important thing second is yes it
suggests that the Fed should start
tightening because the labor market is
getting better and if there is no
tightening eventually there will be
inflation and so when you're looking at
when you say that the labor market
getting better what for you is the most
important indicator do you pay attention
to the labor market conditions index I
know your know your finance academic
economists are not a academic and not a
macro economist but which indicators
most important I think that the quit
chart is a very important one I think
that I would pay a lot of attention to
that the week you wanted the German
10-year yield this morning at seventy
four basis points say to you it says
that the crisis in Europe is not over
so I think that that's that's a problem
not just for you but for the world
economy overall I think that the one of
the reason why Yellen is not sure about
whether to raise rates is because she's
concerned about a slowdown a global
slowdown that can come also from from
Europe